Jennifer Garner celebrated a milestone
birthday in a major way it was just a
blast yeah Jen's 50 flirty and
definitely thriving
in a new cover story for Town and
Country the actress shares she threw a
big blowout party in honor of turning
the big 5-0 quote I basically had a
wedding for myself I was so shocked that
I was doing it now Jin didn't share too
many details about the bash but fans
were quick to pick up the reference to a
wedding seeing as her ex Ben Affleck
just had one of his own this year tying
the knot with another gen Jennifer Lopez
feeling so lucky it's not often you get
a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky after their July
ideas A source told E.T the pair's exes
Garner and Marc Anthony have been
supportive and that the newlyweds and
their former partners plan to celebrate
the holidays as one big family they've
got five kids between them I'm gonna do
our best but back to Genji's b-day yeah
we know she's not one to make a day all
about herself and she owns up to that
confessing to Town and Country she wound
up turning her party into a charity
drive have causes that we care so much
about that we dedicate time resources
and our energy toward making our own
little slice of the world a little bit
better Jennifer says she put everyone to
work getting all her guests to fill 5
000 backpacks with enough food to feed a
family of four there's a reason she's
known as one of the nicest celebs in
Tinseltown thank you Jen actually
addresses that label on the mag too
saying quote I have no reason not to be
nice my life is lovely I like my life
I'm not looking to go anywhere still she
admits she's not always as sweet as she
looks I can also be salty and I can be
taciturn or I can be really serious
about what I want to get done I'm a
tough
I'm not afraid to stand up for myself
when that happens I don't want you to be
shocked that I'm a real person oh and we
love you for it Jen always keeps it real
on Instagram
[Music]
that's good
ever since she joined in 2017 fans have
been falling in love with every sweet
and often candid look inside the
actress's home sometimes I do something
called pretend cooking show on my on
Instagram modern comfort food
everything in here is
exactly what you want to be cooked cook
exactly what you want to be eating right
now
right now sorry I'm supposed to be
talking to you but I can't crispy
chicken with lemon orzo basically this
is what I want to have for lunch so this
is what I'm gonna make
from home cooking shows to singing in
the car to throwing herself her own
wedding we hope Jen keeps making it nice
on and offline
[Music]